Pachinko is an epic journey
of four generations
of a Korean family.
Through years, we watch a girl
grow up from a teenager
into a woman.
This is the story of Sunja.
A poor Korean girl
who becomes pregnant
and has to travel far from
home to start a new life
in a country that
doesn’t even want her.
It’s about Sunja’s
soul and determination
and her power to survive.
Every country has
their own history.
Sometimes it’s beautiful, but
sometimes it’s ugly.
One of the things that I
was so interested in was
what if you could create a show
where the third generation
has at least
some kind of thematic dialogue
with the first generation.
There’s a sacrifice of that
first generation
and the burden that it becomes
on the third generation.
It's incredibly ambitious,
the scale of the storytelling
and how many
generations we follow.
When I read the script
I was blown away,
by the storytelling and the
scope and the size of the story.
We travel from New York to
Korea, Japan.
You needed that
global lens.
I think every family has
a Sunja in their life.
Regardless if you’re Korean,
regardless if you’re from
an immigrant family.
This experience of
leaving a homeland
to forge a new life
somewhere else
because you want a better
opportunity for your children.
We are the result of the trials
and tribulations and experiences
and decisions made by those who
came before us.
Kanpai!